love the blonde hair as well thank you  it's the last color I have yet to do on  my head check out Katy Perry sporting  her platinum blonde locks for the may  cover of Vogue magazine inside the 32  year old singer talks being sober for a  month saying she sometimes wants to  quote cleanse her mind and declare she's  much more grounded since her 20s quote I  learned a lot of lessons patience the  art of saying know that everything  doesn't have to end in marriage the  chain to the rhythm singer even explains  why she stopped celebrating Valentine's  Day Katie says quote it's just so  pressure field it's not easy loving me  just weeks after this Vogue interview  conducted on februari 14th news broke  that Katie in Orlando Bloom have split  after one year of dating everyone's a  teacher in a relationship that's how I  see it now and we've taught each other a  lot  you